allez Peter oui bientôt c'est
réconfortant de voir tant de
visages de nuna étranges ici aujourd'hui je sais que ma mère serait
très touchée et probablement un peu
méfiante ma mère était une femme très
secrète et privée c'est grand-mère
tu sais que tu étais sa préférée sous la
pluie  même ici un petit bébé elle
ne me laissait pas te nourrir car elle
avait besoin de te nourrir c'était une
femme très difficile ce qui m'explique peut-être
je te reconnais de ta mère
ce que parfois je jure je peux les sentir
dans la chambre
elle n'est pas  partie
elle avait des rituels privés amis privés
il va prendre soin de moi tu ne penses pas
que je vais prendre soin de toi mais
quand tu es mort
elle n'était pas tout à fait là à la fin
je ne pense pas que ce papa je ne le fasse pas  Comme ça,
je ne veux plus mettre de stress
sur ma famille